[Music]
hello my name is arun akay i'm the ceo
of cloud limbs welcome to my talk
struggling to follow the usda's new hemp
testing rules limbs makes it easy
so as many of you must know the usda
released the hemp testing regulations as
part of the farm bill of 2018
followed by the interim final rule and
then the final rule which just took
effect from january 1st of this year
so we're going to be going over
the
what is the usda's new hemp testing
rules why should hemp growers and
laboratories follow it and how can hemp
fasting labs meet the regulatory
guidelines and quality standards with
ease
so first let's go through a little bit
of the history of hemp legalization so
in 1937 a law was passed called the
marijuana act
previous to the marijuana act both
cannabis and hemp were perfectly legal
they were used in a number of indigenous
cultures by native americans
and
there was actually quite widespread use
of cannabis
then for
reasons unknown to me the federal
government banned cannabis with the
marijuana act and along with it hemp the
plant itself was banned so that growing
the plant regardless of thc levels was
illegal
it remained this way until 2014.
in 2014 the agricultural act
reintroduced industrial hemp production
in the u.s now this was done at the
federal level but was regulated at the
state level so the federal government
authorized a number of states to apply
for and then be able to do state pilot
programs to test what would happen uh
with legalization of hemp and this came
on the heels of cannabis deregulation
so once this was passed four states
opted to run pilot programs these were
colorado indiana kentucky and vermont
but it was pretty much colorado so
colorado accounted for 97 of the acreage
and the amount of land being used for
hemp production increased from zero
prior to 2014 to 1900 acres and now it
is increased to 150 000 acres
after these growths after these
improvements
in terms of the regulatory bodies as
well as the increase in acreage for hemp
production the next major change came in
2018.
in 2018 hemp was legalized without the
use of any of these state pilot programs
at the federal level
so it was now legal at the federal level
in all 50 states
but all of the regulations moved from
the state's pilot program to the federal
level and the regulation is under the
usda
what was in the 2018 farm bill
so the u.s
u.s 2018 farm bill put hemp
out from under the jurisdiction of the
dea and the controlled substances act
and created and
put hemp as an agricultural commodity
however due to it being the same plant
as cannabis in order to determine
what particular plants would fall under
cannabis and then be under dea
controlled substances act versus being
hemp which would be under the usda
testing requirements were introduced
based on the thc level so it is the thc
level that determines is this cannabis
or is this hemp since cannabis and hemp
are actually the exact same plant
the usda's interim final rule
the usda's interim final rule
governed sampling
testing methods
and phc level
regulations for the disposal of hot hemp
and licensing requirements
so first with the interim final role a
15-day window was given to collect
samples before harvest
the window was extended to 30 days in
the final roll so 30 days before the
final harvest
any grower can actually call in the
testing lab have the sampling done and
then certify that it is actually hemp
that it meets all the regulatory
requirements not be classified as
cannabis
the sampling was also extended to
require the basic statistical sampling
so enough sample needs to be collected
to ensure at a 95 confidence level that
no more than one percent of the plants
in the lot will exceed the 0.3 thc level
threshold this is very similar to
environmental or water quality or any
other statistical sampling method used
by analytical testing labs so prior to
this many of the growers were not doing
the sampling randomly they would
basically either grow a lower thc plant
or they would pick instead of picking it
from the top of the plant they would
pick only leaves and stems resulting in
incorrectly low
thc measurements that is no longer
acceptable the sampling is now being
done by the laboratories as per standard
statistical sampling methods
next was the testing methodology so this
has two parts
one is the way thc levels are measured
and the other is the types of tests
employed for the thc level it is now
delta nine plus thc so instead of only
being able to measure the thc level
because delta nine thca converts to thc
there's a formula and it is added
together and the total dry weight
percentage is the total tac level
then there were specifications for how
the thc level should be uh measured
the only acceptable ways are post
decarboxylation or similarly reliable
methods the lower cost lower accuracy
thc methods are no longer legal under
the usda regulations
third disposal of hotham so we'll be
going into this in more detail later but
basically there are three categories of
hem
0.3 or lower
0.3 up until 1 percent and 1 percent and
higher so lower than 0.3 it is not hot
hemp it is temp and it can be sold and
it is all set to go
above one percent it is not hemp it is
cannabis and it's actually
there can actually be legal citations to
the grower for illegally growing
cannabis this generally doesn't happen
because the limit was increased from the
interim final rule of 0.5
up to 1
so generally you don't accidentally grow
it above the one percent level
between point three percent and one
percent the hemp is considered hot hemp
and there's only two courses of action
for hot hemp one is disposal and the
other is remediation so for disposal
previously under the state's pilot
programs many of the states allowed for
off-site disposal so the whole crop
could be harvested put onto trucks and
sent out supposedly for disposal but the
issue that was happening is it would
often be diverted and actually be used
as cannabis so in order to prevent that
the usda regulation under the final rule
is that all of the hot hemp must be
disposed of on-site so acceptable
methods include plowing under deep
burial and burning but no off-site
and finally licensing requirements every
grower every farmer needs to obtain a
license and registration either from the
state branch of their usda from the
tribal territory or directly from the
usda
the usda's final rule so the final rule
became effective in march of last year
all the hemp testing labs should now be
fully uh compliant with them because the
uh pipe the window in which one could
still follow the state regulations
passed on december 31st so now all
testing labs and all growers must comply
with the usda's final role
and the changes that were introduced
affect all 56
so we've discussed what is the final
rule and what was in the 2018 farm bill
so now why would hemp growers and
testing labs want to require well it's
now legally required in all 50 states
there was a time period in one watch in
which individual labs and growers could
still follow the state pilot testing
rules but that window is now passed now
all laboratories and all growers must
comply
nlt is for hothap so hot hemp as we've
discussed is illegal it is growing
cannabis without a license and
laboratories may get warnings or may be
closed down and the possibility of
prosecution does exist for growing hot
hemp so
this is for anything that's one percent
or higher
for
sampling in order to determine what is
hemp and what is cannabis
the plant parts that will be tested have
been modified so now all of the sampling
must be done from the top five to eight
inches of the main stem
terminal bud or central cola of the
flowering tip
previously many of the growers who were
doing their own sampling would just use
the leaves or stems or some other part
of the plant which has a much lower thc
percentage that is no longer allowed and
the sampling is done by the testing lab
so the testing lab will send personnel
out who will do the sampling they're
going to collect the sample from the top
five to eight inches of the main stem
terminal better central cola and they're
going to record they're going to take a
photograph of the sample
and they're going to record the exact
gps location and randomly distribute it
throughout the field so that it's
statistically a sampling method all
these standard sampling methods have
already been established for
environmental water quality and other in
the local testing
and testing methods
all hemp testing should use post
decarboxylation
or a similar reliable method the cheaper
less reliable thc measurement systems
are no longer legal under the farm bill
and the thc is the total of the delta
nine plus the thc so it's the total dry
waste basis
total thc limit in order to qualify
attempt the thc threshold must be 0.3
there was a lot of speculation that by
the final rule that it would be
increased to 0.5 percent but the usda
did not do that they maintained it at 3
percent so anything above 0.3 is hot
negligent violation so we discussed
before how anything that is one percent
or above is illegal so these are the
three categories so between uh
lower than point three percent is up so
that can be resolved out of this between
point three percent thc and one percent
the hot hemp can either be remediated
or can be disposed of but in either case
it's not a violation of the law
above one percent and this was an
increase in the interim final rule it
was point five percent it was increased
to one percent so anything above one
percent is a negligent violation which
could be prosecuted which will certainly
result in a warning and possibly have
the license revoked for the grower
remediation
so
i'll put do a little aside here so
remediation became quite popular because
there were a lot of hemp growers whose
products
were grown under the state's pilot
programs and then they were surprised
when they failed in the hemp testing
after the inter after the final world
was passed because they didn't expect it
because they were compliant with the
higher thc limits under the state pilot
programs but they were not meeting the
point three percent so there are a lot
of hemp farmers who then went through
the remediation process the best way to
remediate is to not need to remediate
but to use clones so it's been
determined by numerous studies that the
single biggest component in determining
the thc
final percentage is not based on growing
conditions harvest or any of those it's
based on the plant genetics the controls
of the plant genetics it's easier to use
clones rather than seeds and so by
selecting clones specifically for hemp
with the low thc levels the chance of
needing to do remediation is uh very low
so the best way to remediate is to avoid
it in the first place by picking up
clones
now if it's too late if you already have
a complete harvest and you need to
remediate the way you do it is you
remove the flowers
so you'll need to take all of the hemp
have hand cutting of all the flowers
done which are then disposed of through
one of the acceptable processes and the
rest of the plant is put into an
instrument like you can see here
where a uniform biomass is created by
mulching together
all of the leaves stems and other parts
of the plant minus the flowers and this
uniform biomass can then be retested or
being compliant with the 0.3
so that's the remediation process
measurement of uncertainty so this
should have already been included in any
standard lab but now it's regulated
under the farm bill that when the phd
level is reported it's not reported as
is it also means to have the plus or
minus so for example uh for hemp it
could be 0.2
plus or minus 0.05
operational changes
hemp testing labs must use validated
test methods so this is part of qa qc
every test method must have gone through
qaqc
the lab should have appropriate quality
assurance protocols in place
and the usd encourages does not does not
require
laboratories to be 1705 compliant now
most
cannabis labs are already 17.025
compliant because most states require
17025 compliance
and since there are very few
laboratories that are doing only hemp
testing on cannabis they tend to be the
same labs
it's very it's by default most
laboratories will just be 17025
compliant for both cannabis and hemp
managing qc samples and their test
results
so in order to be 1705 compliant or to
meet the farm bill's qaqc requirements
a laboratory needs to have measurement
traceability
so periodically mixed in with a sample
there need to be blinks spikes and
duplicates
this way you can ensure that let's say
uh every sample is turning out with the
php percentage of zero
most likely they're not actually zero
most likely there is a bad reagent or
some other problem with the test which
is why it's resulting in zero and that
can be determined by a spike
so a spike where a known thc level
sample is placed in mixed in with the
other samples will show that in fact if
there is thc present it is being
correctly detected same thing with
blinks and same things with duplicates
which show that the reproducibility that
if if a particular sample is found to be
0.2
thc that that same
sample from that same batch when tested
again will still be 0.2
plus or minus the measurement of
uncertainty
dea registration
all hemp testing labs must be registered
by the dea by the end of this year so by
december 31st of 2022
all laboratories must be registered with
the dea and the reason for this is
simple it's because until a particular
sample is actually tested and found to
be below 0.3
it could still be cannabis it could
still be
above 0.3 in which case there's a
different set of regulations and it
falls under the controlled substances
act
reporting of total thc
so the reporting of thc needs to be on a
total dry weight basis which includes
the delta nine
thca plus the thc so this is another
reason why many of the labs that were
previously passing under the state pilot
programs are now failing and being found
to be
hot hemp under the usda's regulations
because not only has the limits been
lowered from 0.5 to 0.3 but in addition
to that the delta 9 is being factored in
as chc because it does converge or it
can convert and so because of that the
total thc levels are
often going above so again this is the
reason for using clones with a known low
thc genetics
of test results so once the a test is
performed the test results need to be
shared both with a licensed producer and
with the usda
so this is done by having the results
come in through your coa and the coa is
then going to be distributed to both the
producer
to the state or tribal authority and
directly to the usda
so this is an example of a custom coa
you'll want your limbs to be able to
produce custom coas because you'll need
one coa that's usda compliant for all of
your hemp tests and then for every state
because that's still not legal on a
federal level every state has a
different set of testing requirements of
what needs to be on the coa to meet that
state's requirements so let's say you
have a set of laboratories that are
operating in five different states
you will need to have a minimum of six
coas because you'll need a hemp coa for
the usda
and you will need for each one of those
five states a different coa customized
for that state that contains all of the
pesticides the thc level the
cannabinoids required under that state
and there's quite a bit of variation
between states
so cloud limbs for example will take the
test results and directly interface to
the usda uploading all the results and
directly interface to the state tribal
um authorities in order to send the hemp
results to them and in addition to that
it will interface with metric leaf and
biotrack on the cannabis side so that
all of those can comply with the state
regulations
other significant changes to hemp
testing
all of the samples must be homogeneous
so when your sample comes in it's going
to be ground up so there's a uniform
sample
in the case of retesting because what
some laboratories were doing because
they wanted the growers to pass
if the initial tests failed then they
would just retest and sometimes they
would retest with a non-homogeneous
sample they could actually cherry pick
areas that didn't contain the flower so
that's no longer possible because the
samples are homogeneous and in order to
retest which is still allowed the
laboratory has to follow their own
internal sop or when and how re-testing
should be done
then because the laboratory may have
received samples that are above the 0.3
percent
meaning that it is now cannabis they
have to have a disposal procedure for
the hot tub just like they do for the
cannabis because if it's above 0.3
it's considered cannabis so all of the
controlled substances act regulations
apply
how to choose the right limbs for your
lab
well when you're going about picking a
limbs you will want one that integrates
with the usda
and the state department of agriculture
so that you can send the hemp test
results to them
you'll want it to have all of the qa qc
processes now some limbs are only sample
management so if it's only sample
management you're gonna have to buy a
second product with the qaqc in order to
become 1705 compliant so it's simpler
and easier to have a single limb that
covers both of these so when you're
evaluating limbs make sure it has both
sample management plus qaqc
you'll want to be able to generate
custom certificates of analysis so for
other industries so for example for
clinical diagnostics
generally there's no certificate of
analysis needed a test result comes out
it doesn't require custom formatting and
the results are very straightforward but
for cannabis and hemp custom
certificates of analysis are necessary
because they need to meet each one of
the state regulations you'll want a
custom coa
you'll need all the other 7025
compliances such as tracking of stop
training and their competency management
of documents sops and version histories
and instrument calibration and
maintenance data
in addition to the basic sample
management so all of these are essential
when evaluating a limbs to make sure
that it's going to do everything that a
hemp and probably cannabis as well
testing laboratory requires
so the benefits of deploying a hemp
limbs are
increased test accuracy higher
productivity higher quality and lower
cost basically you don't have to repeat
tests so if you're not follow if you're
not using a limbs and you don't not
tracking the qa qc not only will not be
compliant there is a much higher
likelihood that you'll need to repeat
tests causing much lower throughput and
higher costs
so we've covered what are the usda's
hemp testing roles they're the most
important federal rules governing hemp
production
why does the lab need to follow it it's
now legally required in all 50 states no
more pilot state testing programs that
expired at the end of last year
and have you achieve it deploy a limbs
preferably a limbs with both sample
management and qaqc
so
thank you very much are there any
questions
how do you dispose of hot hemp so
as i had mentioned before the best way
is to not get hot hemp in the first
place so use clones don't use seeds use
a clone which is known to have a low uh
thc production they're now quite
standard and the cost of clones is very
much not that high compared to the value
of the plant at the end and it's worth
it to not have to do the remediation so
the easiest way to not need to do it
the second way is to remediate so unless
as hop did happen in the first batch
that came out unless the price of hemp
is super low you're probably going to
want to try to remediate so then you
have to have probably by humans snip off
all of the flowers take all of the
product mulch it all together to produce
that uniform biomass and
then you have it remediated
or third to actually dispose of it you
need to do plowing under mulching
composting deep burial burning which is
the most dramatic but not that efficient
all of those are legal ways but you
cannot transport offsite
other questions
so the best and easiest way to remediate
is
got to snip off all the flowers
use one of the commercially produced
these all come from agribusiness there
are machines that will take the plant
and mash it all together into what they
call a homogeneous biomass and that can
then be retested for thc compliance
chances are after the removal of the
flowers the uh final mass will be well
below the point three percent thc limit
i'll take one more question
uh yes so our limbs and hopefully any
limbs that you would purchase but make
sure of it uh report directly to the
usda it reports directly to the state
and tribal for the hemp side and then in
addition to that if you're also using
the limbs for cannabis it integrates
with
uh metric bio track and leaf so it
covers all
in california so it covers all of the
state regulations for cannabis as well
so um i think that'll be it because i'm
out of time now so uh if you have any
more questions just put them into the
chat and i think that they're going to
get emailed to me and i promise i will
apply to all questions by email
thank you very much
welcome to welcome to the end of my talk
thank you
you